this is the hope hostel in kigali and if
that flight goes ahead this is where
asylum seekers will be housed it's a
hundred a hundred capacity 50 twin
bedrooms and it's been set up so that
the people feel as comfortable as
possible here quite clearly there's a
bedroom which we can take a look at one
of those double bedrooms which two
people can stay in there's wardrobes as
well that there there's obviously
amenities on the table too again it's
all geared towards trying to make it
feel as homely as possible you can see
those slippers there in the little
compartment at the bottom as well
it's an attempt at making this place
well look as look as as normal as can be
when they land in kigali there's also
communal areas in this building as well
including the bathrooms here which will
be shared we also have this this area
too there's prayer rooms in this
building as well and it's interesting
i've been here once before in april when
the plans were first announced and one
thing that has changed is the fact that
there are now signs all over the area in
arabic for example take this laundry
sign for example so they've obviously
realized that a number of the asylum
seekers coming over from the uk will be
from countries in the middle east and
they've done their best to accommodate
that there's also halal food here as
well
there are um
there's a gift shop too in which people
can buy their own food
essentials and cigarettes but it's quite
clearly an attempt to try and make this
place as comfortable as possible